i'm very happy and very content
and it's such a good feeling as things
heat up between kim kardashian and pete
davidson a source tells e.t they've been
involving each other more and more with
their respective families and friends
why not the source says the lovebirds
are going strong and very happy in their
relationship
i love that quote pete is so into kim
and is constantly doing romantic sweet
things for her to make her feel loved
and special as for kim the source adds
that she feels so comfortable around
pete and is continuing to focus on their
relationship growing together and moving
forward without any negativity
yep and as they continue to get closer
and closer the source says they're
bringing each other around their friends
and family more and more in fact when
e.t caught up with kim's bestie jonathan
chebin back in february he said pete has
his seal of approval i think it's cool
you know what she's having fun i guess
you know uh you know i i've hung out
with them a couple of times and
you know i love her to death so whatever
whatever makes her happy
and caitlyn jenner also seems to love
the couple he was over the other day she
met him for the first show like skeeting
i called i was in trouble because i
called him peter and kim starts laughing
it's not peter it's pete i said well i
don't know i'm just trying to be
polite and to be honest with you
uh he seemed like a very nice guy
honestly kim seems so happy
and that's my number one concern
and according to et source the 28 year
old saturday night live star is
definitely making her happy it's really
lit and fun and crazy quote they felt
like the timing was right to take things
further and they are enjoying getting
even closer and learning more about each
other everyone around them has been
supportive of their relationship and
they both fit in perfectly with each
other's loved ones we are so blessed to
have the best support system and the
best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through and when
it comes to all those romantic gestures
that i mentioned earlier we saw it on
full display earlier this week
we had to carry in a huge bouquet of
flowers at pizza in here for you does
that make the other boyfriends look bad
i didn't know that happened until right
now yeah it all went down during a stop
by jimmy kimmel live with her famous
sisters and mommager on wednesday to
promote their new hulu series premiering
april 14th this is a relationship that i
don't think anybody saw coming from who
are you texting ken does his name rhyme
with feet
the two started dating after kim hosted
snl back in october and made headlines
after they puckered up in this aladdin
sketch
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
kim is this the first time you kissed
pete
yes that is
so naturally when valentine's day rolled
around pete went super sentimental and
got kim a gift with meaning
for valentine's day he got me the rug in
the whole outfits he did and the little
genie oh wow he is
[Music]
you